>>> U.S. VETERAN DANE PARTRIDGE
HAS BECOME THE FIFTH KNOWN
AMERICAN TO BE KILLED WILD
VOLUNTEERING IN UKRAINE.
HE DIED THIS WEEK FROM INJURIES
THAT HE SUSTAINED AFTER HE AND
OTHERS WERE AMBUSHED BY TWO
RUSSIAN VEHICLES WHILE THEY WERE
CLEARING TRENCHES.
THE FATHER OF FIVE SUFFERED A
BROKEN NECK AND WOUNDS TO HIS
BRAIN FROM SHRAPNEL.
HE WAS IN A COMA FOR EIGHT DAYS
AND HE PASSED AWAY IN A
ZAPORIZHZHIA HOSPITAL ON TUESDAY
WHILE STILL ON LIFE SUPPORT.
HE HAD BEEN FIGHT AGO LONG SIDE
UKRAINIANS SINCE APRIL AND
JOINING US NOW IS DANE'S SISTER,
JENNY CORRY, I'M SO SORRY FOR
YOUR LOSS AND FOR THE LOSS OF
YOUR FAMILY.
HOW ARE YOU DOING AND HOW ARE
YOU REFLECTING ON WHAT YOUR
BROTHER WAS DOING AT THE TIME
THAT HE DIED?
>> WE'RE DOING OKAY.
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE DEVASTATED.
AT THIS NEWS.
BUT WE -- WE BELIEVE AND KNOW
THAT HE PAID THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE AND WE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW HE JUST
FELT LIKE HE NEEDED TO SERVE AND
BE THERE FOR HIS FELLOW MEN AND
SO THAT IS HOW WE'RE GOING TO GO
ON HONORING HIS NAME AND TELLING
HIS STORY.
>> AND REMEMBERING HIM THROUGH
HIS STORIES AND FOR HIS CHILDREN
AS WELL.
I KNOW HE BOUGHT A ONE-WAY
TICKET TO POLAND.
HE DID SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY
MANY SERVICE MEMBERS DO BEFORE
GOING INTO SERVICE.
WHICH IS HE PREPARED.
HE DRAFTED HIS WILL.
DID YOU HAVE TOUGH
CONVERSATIONS --
>> YES.
>> -- BEFORE HE LEFT ABOUT WHAT
THE POSSIBILITY OF WHAT COULD
HAPPEN?
>> WE TALKED ABOUT IT.
IT IS INTERESTING, BECAUSE PART
OF OUR CONVERSATION WAS IN HIS
EARLIER YEARS, HE HAD RIGHT OUT
OF HIGH SCHOOL AND HE HAD JOINED
THE ARMY AND FOUGHT FOR
OPERATION IRAQI FREEDOM.
HE SAID THIS TIME.
WHEN I WENT TO IRAQ, I WAS
SCARED.
THIS TIME I HAD SUCH A STRONG
CONVICTION AND I KNEW WITH EVERY
BONE IN MY BODY THIS IS RIGHT
AND I'M NOT SCARED AND I KNOW
VERY LIKELY THAT I'M NOT GOING
TO COME BACK.
>> HE THOUGHT THAT.
HE THOUGHT HE MIGHT NOT COME
BACK.
BUT HE THOUGHT IT WAS WORTH IT.
COULD YOU TELL ME MORE ABOUT WHY
HE THOUGHT IT WAS WORTH IT
CONSIDERING HE HAD SO MUCH AT
HOME TO LIVE FOR?
>> YOU SAW A NOBLE CAUSE AND HE
WANTED TO GO FIGHT FOR IT.
AND HE'S THE KIND OF FAITH-BASED
MAN THAT WHEN GETS A PIERCING IN
HIS HEART AND HE KNOWS THAT HE
BELIEVES THAT WITH EVERY BONE IN
HIS BODY, HE CAN'T DENY THAT AND
HE WANTED TO HONOR HIS GOD AN
THE CONVICTION THAT HE GOT TO GO
FIGHT.
>> CAN YOU TELL US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HIM, JENNY.
YOU'VE TOLD US ABOUT HIS
CONVICTIONS AND OBVIOUSLY WE
KNOW ABOUT HIS WILLINGNESS TO
SACRIFICE FOR THOSE CONVICTIONS.
COULD YOU TELL US A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT HIM?
>> YES.
HE WAS KIND OF GUY THAT HE WOULD
HELP ANYBODY.
BUT HE ALSO LIKED BEING THE LIFE
OF THE PARTIES.
HE WAS A TALL, KIND OF A LOUD
BOOMING VOICE AND YOU KNEW HE
WAS IN THE ROOM.
AND HE LOVED TO MAKE PEOPLE
LAUGH.
HE LOVED TO BE WITTY.
IF YOU WERE SAD, HE WANTED TO
CLEAR YOU UP.
HE DIDN'T TALK MUCH ABOUT
HIMSELF WHEN HE WAS OVER THERE
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T WANT US TO
WORRY, HE JUST WANTED US TO
CONNECT AT HOME AND KEEP THINGS
AS HAPPY AS HE COULD SO THAT WE
WEREN'T WORRYING SO MUCH FOR
HIM.
BUT HE WAS ONE TO -- WHEN HE SAW
A NEED, HE WAS GOING TO REACH
OUT AND HE WAS GOING TO TAKE
CARE OF SOMEBODY WHETHER THEY
NEEDED HELP, WHETHER THEY WERE
SAD, WHETHER THEY NEEDED
CHEERING UP.
HE JUST WANTED TO BE THAT PERSON
TO LIFT PEOPLE UP.
>> JENNY, HE SOUNDS LIKE HE WAS
AN AMAZING PERSON.
AND I'M SO SORRY FOR WHAT YOU
ARE GOING THROUGH AND FOR WHAT
YOUR FAMILY IS GOING THROUGH.
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR SHARING
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HIM WITH US
THIS MORNING.
JENNY CORRY, THANK YOU.